eu estava no carnaval de rua no bairro
da vila madalena quando um cara me
encantou não estava interessada
ignorei por causa disso ele decidiu
puxar pelo cabelo
olhei para ele e falei sou louco
então ele chutou minha perna com toda a
força que ele tinha e eu percebi que os
amigos desse rapaz tiveram segurá lo
porque ele quer debater mais desnorteado
e fui procurar ajuda e fui atrás de um
policial mas todo policial que
encontrava me dizer a mesma coisa
não posso me deslocar até lá então eu
liguei para o 190 eo atendente me falou
que infelizmente não tinha nada que lhe
podia fazer é humilhada com dor e sem
ajuda e fui para casa e esse cara que me
violentou continua lá provavelmente
bebendo mais batendo outras mulheres
essa história é narrada aqui pra vocês
foi contada pela própria vítima
no mapa colaborativa online da chegada
de um fio a chega de ver o filme a
campanha que eu criei há dois anos atrás
para combater o assédio sexual em locais
públicos
qualquer pessoa pode acessar esse mapa e
fazer um reporte de alguma violência de
gênero ou de assédio que sofreu
então quando eu fui convidada para falar
aqui pra vocês eu pensei eu tenho que
trazer uma história que mostra todas as
camadas de dor e humilhação de trauma
and e de injustiça que o assédio sexual
carrega consigo mostrar com nocivo é a
sociedade
então agora você saia com vocês e fala
que eu nem preciso ir muito longe
eu simplesmente narrei a primeira
história que foi reportada nosso mapa
quando ele foi ao ar e assim como ela
tem muitas outras
só nessa nova ferramenta que uma micro
micro micro amostra do que realmente
acontece no país
a gente tem mais de 1.600 denúncias
gente todas elas são preocupantes e
todas elas são igualmente urgentes a
chega de fio nasceu de medos e anseios
muito pessoais
então acho que não faz muito sentido
falar sobre elas em conta a minha
própria história com a sad a ver né
ela vem quando tinha 11 anos o meu corpo
me traiu
é uma estranha em meu peito cresceu o
rapidinho percebi que só se muito um
grande problema porque eu era capitão do
tipo de queimada da 4ª série e as
cólicas nem o corpo mais sensível ela
tinha uma desvantagem quadra mas eu
tenho percebi que esse realmente é ser o
menor dos problemas
os meus colegas de sala eles perceberam
a mudança corporal porque é óbvia e aí
eles vão me perguntar se eu estava
usando enchimento
eu tinha colocado silicone ou se eu
estava grávida eu tinha 11 anos
alguns queriam encostar no meu peito
talvez seja verdade e os adultos que são
amigos conhecidos da família eles vão
falar que eu nunca tive tão bonita nunca
foi tão mulherão
eles vinham falar pros meus pais é super
na boa intenção que eles iam comprar mas
porque daqui a pouco os gaviões não
ficar sobrevoando aquilo que parecia
muito mais um pedaço de carne do que a
filha deles lá
essa foi a minha primeira experiência
com um conceito de coco de que o corpo
da mulher não é dela
o corpo da mulher é público a minha
segunda experiência com esse conceito
ela foi já é bem mais violenta
eu era uma menina de 11 anos que acusa
vida girava em torno de jogos de
queimada do mundo de vítima
cavaleiros do zodíaco mas os homens nas
ruas não eles achavam que estava na hora
de falar sobre sexo
eles me convidavam para transar convite
eles comentavam sobre a minha vagina
eles mostravam seus pênis do transporte
público eles encostavam no meu corpo eu
ficava claro horrorizada
eu me sentia sendo intimidada e
humilhado
eu tinha medo que tinha nojo mas eu nem
no meu também nunca me sentindo segura
para falar com ninguém sobre isso porque
é a primeira vez que eu tentei foi um
desafio vou contar pra vocês
a primeira vez que eu sofria assédio foi
no caminho da padaria para minha casa e
eu chorei
senhora me viu chorando pelo caminho foi
tentar me consolar
quando eu contei pra ela que tinha
acontecido ela me disse que eu era boba
não deveria estar chorando por isso
tinha que aceitar tecnologia e ser algo
bom e será positivo e quando tiver a
idade dela ia sentir falta o ok né então
desde cedo e entendi que tinha que
aceitar como algo positivo até aquilo
que me machucava e por medo de parecer
com a mona cometida eu me calei
mas quando fiz 28 anos uma coisa mudou
na minha vida
o diretor de teatro já thomaz está
lançando um livro
ele foi entrevistado por uma panicat
chamada nicole boss
ela está usando aquela roupa de panicat
que é um vestido curto sem falas são tão
alto
entre uma pergunta e outra o diretor de
teatro achou por bem colocar a mão por
baixo do vestido dela sem consentimento
vocês provavelmente se lembra dessa
história eu fiquei horrorizada com aqui
mano mas aquilo também estourou uma
bolha em que eu vivia porque nas redes
sociais pessoas que eu conhecia e
admirava estavam defendendo a atitude do
geral thomas e foi aí que eu percebi uma
coisa a gente acha que o machista e o
assediador é esse homem sem rosto
esse homem desconhecido pela rua que
abusa das mulheres nas ruas escuras não
é
esses assediadores eles são pais são
filhos são profissionais competentes que
estão mais perto do que a gente imagina
é aquele chefe que admira é seu colega
de trabalho que tem um doutorado é
aquele amigo que é carinhoso engraçado
porque porque o assédio é legítimo
culturalmente
ele é entendido como algo que faz parte
do homem
entendido como algo bom com flash
mas não é isso precisava mudar tava
claro na minha cabeça eu tinha que fazer
alguma coisa mas o que né
bom sou jornalista que me restava
escrever sobre isso então eu escrevi
algumas revistas femininas
nossa cofre eu fui lavar uma
especificamente e falei que era
importantíssimo a gente falar sobre a
sede a falar como ele é nocivo e começa
a culpabilização da vítima também é
nociva e que é importante a gente fazer
essa discussão num veículo em stream
como aquele porque ajudará até mesmo
aquelas mulheres que sofrem caladas como
eu sofria
e aí eu recebi a resposta da editora era
uma frase assim não sei jo eu acho que
isso é patrulhamento do politicamente
correto eu fiquei super chateada
eu chorei também a falar isso mas eu
chorei na época porque poxa gente falar
sobre violência contra a mulher então
entendido com o patrulhamento beleza
ainda bem que essa é a era da internet
ea gente pode criar um conteúdo próprio
sem muito custo então decidi fazer
chegar de chuva por conta própria
a gente começou publicando algumas
inseri-los ações nossas redes
e se vocês vão forem olhar só elas são
super coloridas elas são até bem
humoradas net qual ele é subiu pra mim
agora vou dar mole disse ninguém nunca
fala tem um certo humor mas elas têm uma
mensagem forte que é assédio é sem
violência
a gente não vai mais aceitar o assédio
ea gente vai retomar as ruas que são
nossos por direita
essas situações de forma totalmente
orgânica vira finalizaram na internet ea
partir daí dezenas de mulheres começaram
a escrever e estavam dividindo comigo as
suas próprias histórias concede seus
traumas seus medos e muitas delas
estavam dirigindo pela primeira vez com
uma estranha do outro lado do computador
a partir daí a gente pensou pô vamos
fazer um estudo mais profundo sobre essa
relação da mulher com a sad a gente
colocou um questionário online querendo
fazer uma pesquisa para entender
exatamente como a gente começa às
mulheres enxergavam isso nessa violência
vou falar a verdade eu esperava que as
amigas e meus amigos e amigas
respondessem nossa pesquisa em menos de
duas semanas oito quase 8 mil mulheres
responderam à pesquisa ou vieram atrás
elas queriam participar elas queriam
falar sobre isso seria um dá a sua fala
nessa
agência e aí essa aqui é os nossos
resultados são 83% não gostam de
encantadas
dessas oito mulheres 81% já deixaram de
fazer alguma coisa com medo de assédio
90% já trocaram de roupa por medo de
assédio e 85 já sofreram com a mão boba
qualquer mulher que circula pelo
ambiente público sabe que essa é uma
realidade mas tem esses dados no papel
foi muito forte
a partir daí a imprensa começou a ter
muito interesse no debate sobre assédio
sexual na chegada do filme eu acabei
dando entrevistas para vários jornais
revistas rádios e tv do brasil inteiro e
até alguns gringos mas claro que a
mudança ela não é algo que vem muito
fácil a gente também feliz com a nossa
campanha
alguns jornalistas e um em alguns
colunistas famosos
falavam que acompanhar um lixo que é uma
menina mimada que queria capturar homens
um dos portais local da entrevista fez
uma matéria que o titular assim assédio
sexual violência contra a mulher ou
minimize de rede social
esse comportamento responsável mandou um
sentimento de vários homens que não
estavam felizes com a campanha também ea
partir daí eles começaram a me ofender
na internet
ele xingava eles não passavam de estupro
em minha primeira me ameaçavam de morte
eu fiquei super estressado não conseguia
dormir
eu estava meio deprimido não confia
comer em cinco dias - cinco dias já
tinha perdido três quilos
mas vejam só que interessante essa mesma
internet que me colocava em contato com
esses criminosos de forma tão fácil me
colocou em contato com milhares de
outras pessoas que apoiavam a campanha e
me apoiava incondicionalmente inclusive
havendo algumas delas aqui na nossa
platéia pediu rafa e aí por causa dessas
pessoas eu consegui me reerguer e eu
decidi que eu não ia votar
a situação de medo de silêncio então que
agora quer compartilhar com vocês
algumas das conquistas na chegada de um
filho que a gente conseguiu desde então
o primeiro é o mapa
chega de vil como falei no começo é uma
ferramenta onde qualquer pessoa pode
acessar para fazer sua denúncia de
violência de gênero ea idéia é
justamente mapear as áreas mais críticas
do país inteiro isso aqui é são paulo e
todos os pins azuis são já são uma
denúncia
é o legal dessa ferramenta claro a gente
quer mapear esses espaços não vai falar
que a mulher não pode passar por ali mas
de fato entender porque eles são assim
problemáticos por exemplo às vezes é uma
rua que não tem iluminação ou será que
um barulho que a segurança os seguranças
não estão atentos para a questão do
assédio mas além de ser uma ferramenta
de denúncia ela virou uma ferramenta de
microtransações nação como é o caso por
exemplo da usuária que entrou no mapa
ela pesquisou bar favorito ela viu que
ali tinham várias denúncias de assédio
imprimiu cada uma das histórias levou
para o gerente falou totó faz alguma
coisa agora a gente tá aqui no papel
mostrando que que está acontecendo no
seu marido toma providência não possua
micro transformação que vocês podem
fazer
contando com essa ferramenta é outra
o folder que a gente fez junto com a
defensoria pública do estado de são
paulo
é uma linguagem super simples e
acessível do que é o assédio sexual
porque ele é problemático e que a vítima
pode fazer e se ele foi
distribuído gratuitamente
isso foi muito legal porque enfim a
chega de filtrar falando é com o setor
público e tem nosso documentário também
um ano a gente bom foram foi um ano
buscando patrocínio para este
documentário sobre a chegada de um fio
eo assédio sem conseguir então decidiu
fazer um financiamento coletivo é o
nossa meta 20 mil reais e não for falar
em orçamento era bem apertado
não sei se vocês sabem como funciona mas
normalmente nos financiamentos coletivos
e cunha meta
a cada doação que a pessoa faz você dá
algo em troca como recompensa
a gente não tinha como oferecer nada
material a gente vocês uma coisa tipo se
você nos deram dez reais você vai ter
nossa gratidão eterna que é uma verdade
mas não chega pelo correio na casa de
ninguém
cruzamos os dedos e formas em menos de
24 horas a gente bateu nossa meta
brigada foi menos 24 horas um recorde
desse site de financiamento coletivo da
categoria cinema é o nosso projeto foi o
mais a que mais rapidamente recado a
meta entre todas as categorias do site
nós somos quatro projeto então poxa foi
muito legal isso né porque eu percebi
que eu não sou uma pessoa maluca
eu não sou louca tem várias outras
pessoas que também acham que é urgente
debater a questão do assédio tanto é que
elas deram seu suado dinheirinho para
nosso documentário nos 60 dias de
campanha ao fim de 60 sessenta dias a
gente arrecadou 65 mil reais com a ajuda
de mais de 1200 pessoas lindas e
maravilhosas
foi muito legal e por fim as pessoas me
perguntam mas você acha que você
conseguiu fazer alguma transformação
social pra valer
gente vou falar a verdade pra vocês
ainda nestas mulheres ainda são sediadas
na rua é o que acontece infelizmente mas
pelo menos a gente está falando sobre
isso e mais importante está associando a
violência não fosse isso eu não estaria
aqui no tek falando na história pra
vocês uma ótima história de uma outra
micro transformação que eu acho que
admite a transformação de ea gente chega
até o que a gente quer o nosso sonho eu
estava dando uma palestra sobre a
chegada de um fio no final ter no final
da palestra abrir a perguntas do público
uma menina levantou a mão e falou assim
eu só queria dizer que não importa a
roupa que você tá não importa onde você
está
o assédio é errado
ela tinha nove anos de idade
hoje há nove anos ela já sabe algo que
eu demorei 30 para aprender
então eu sou muito muito otimista e eu
espero que vocês sejam também